A wise crack.
Jared here in the flesh this time,
you guys may or may not know this,
but why Scott conditions take a really
long time and we've been wanting to do
something where we can quickly react to
what's currently on TV or in theaters.
So we,
because we try it out with season three
of rick and morty and hey,
if you like this,
let us know.
We'd love to do these on things like
game of thrones,
stranger things,
wherever this Jake Paul Person Is,
you name it in Rick Man,
the stone we see rick summer and morty
traversing a Mad Max inspired post
apocalypse.
What struck me most about this episode
was an idea that has popped up in
previous episodes but hasn't been as
fleshed out as fan favorites like
existences,
pain and everything you believe his
bullshit scientifically traditions or an
idiot thing.
That idea modern alienation through
April,
right?
Glowing Rock,
a mustachioed murderer and Jerry,
the episode explores another depressing
is guiding that society may be slowly
destroying our soul.
Welcome to this wisecrack quick take on
rick,
managing the stone and of course
spoilers ahead,
but first a quick recap.
Rick Morty in summer infiltrate the
aptly named death stalkers to steal a
glowing rock that rick wants for science
40 and summer.
Use this aggressive world to vent all
they're confused emotions about their
parents' divorce.
Summer does all kinds of acting out and
then falls for a swole dude with a
bucket on his head and eventually goes
through her own divorce.
There he is,
there's the nihilistic brute.
I married allowing her to contextualize
her parents' separation,
morty fences,
frustration by living vicariously
through a revenge driven arm and
eventually realizes he should just let
it go.
Maybe the lesson we've learned is that
whether it's our parents marriage
glowing green rock or an awesome giant
arm,
sooner or later you've got to let it go
and rick acts like a child,
kind of my daughter's going through a
divorce and I am not dealing with it in
a healthy way at all.
Early in the episode we hear Rick
introduced the idea of alienation,
but if you're really that alienated,
I'm as willing to exploit it as the next
Guy Church army or Olympic gymnastics
trainer suggesting that summer's tension
with Jerry has made her disillusioned
and the only thing that can make her
feel alive is to travel to a place where
civilization has crumbled.
Now the cover thing here is that the
show not only tackles alienation on a
micro level,
the family kind that summer and morty
experience,
but on a macro level be alienation of
society as a whole and through this,
the show frames how we lose agency in
our everyday lives.
Hasten point,
Sherry,
I think this quote informs a lot of
what's going on in this episode to live
is to risk it off.
Otherwise you're just in a NERC chunk of
randomly assembled molecules drifting
wherever the universe blows you.
Oh,
I'm sorry Jerry,
I didn't see you there.
How much of that did you hear?
What rick is not so subtly suggesting is
Jerry's complete and utter lack of
personal resolve,
power agency,
whatever you want to call it,
he's a doormat to the world.
This idea of powerlessness informs a lot
of mortise resentment towards Jerry as
evidenced by this group standing in the
driveway talking about custody and
either Kelly or you want to stay married
or get on with your life,
but whatever you do,
stop being a baby.
And this,
I think if dad really wanted to be here,
he'd stop at nothing to make that
happen.
You know,
maybe dad just doesn't want you back.
Or maybe he just doesn't have the
strength to fight.
And in either case,
he's got his life,
I got mine.
But mortise bitterness goes much further
than Jerry's failed marriage.
And that's because in some ways,
jerry is the every man of the modern
world.
Since the days of the industrial
revolution,
people have been complaining about loss
of control in the modern world instead
of having our own trade or farm,
many toil away at monotonous jobs.
This loss of autonomy is reflected on by
countless authors,
scholars,
and films.
But we might as well just throw this
example at you.
See,
y'all need some attention.
Nice.
He's flown.
God dammit and entire generation pumping
gas waiting tables.
Slaves with white cops.
Advertising has is chasing cars and
clothes,
working jobs we hate so we can buy.
We don't need the middle children of
history,
man.
No purpose in place
and this is what frames mortise anger at
Jerry's powerlessness.
Jerry is the pinnacle of modern stew
jury.
His existence as a cog in a meaningless
machine is really driven home in the
Rick Shank.
Redemption or the Galactic Federation
keeps everyone compliant and docile
through a liberal use of
pharmaceuticals.
I Galactic Federation taking over
Earth's best thing that's ever happened
to his family.
I just got my six promotion this week
and I still don't know what I do.
In other words,
jerry is so bad at being a person.
He thrives in a society devoid of
freedom.
Summer show your father some respect.
He's pulling down a six chewable figure
income.
His inability to assert himself is put
on display in every interaction he has
with rick.
Of course there is a version of Jerry
who isn't in Rick's words and a nerd
chunk of randomly assembled molecules
drifting wherever the universe bloats
and that would be jerry from
Cronenberg's when stripped of the
trappings of modern society,
Carey goes from being a useless hack in
a loveless marriage to a total badass
who seems to be keeping his marriage
together.
This in itself is hilarious,
but with this latest episode,
I think Rick and more use playing with
this idea that the trappings of modern
society are inherently alienating and
create Jerry's out of all of us.
After rick introduces electricity to the
wasteland,
it's soon resembles a modern
industrialized society.
Summers,
violent lifestyle has been traded in for
every day.
Banalities she is an out murdering ubs.
She's grocery shopping for human bits.
The savagery of the death stalkers has
been reduced to complaining about
recycling and hemorrhage.
The murdering machine,
is that what good for nothing.
Couch potato.
You haven't moved since I left to
scavenge this morning.
What's so clever here is the implication
that modern comforts are what drive our
banal,
terrible lives with no mutans to fend
off people resort to bickering about
trivialities.
We noticed that you've been put in scrap
metal in the boom.
I got it.
Due to electricity.
People aren't murdering each other in
the blood dome.
They're watching blood doe see most post
apocalyptic fiction functions as a
cautionary tale of how awful our lives
might become.
But of course,
being the darkest show on TV,
rick and morty goes out of its way to
prove that modern life is its own
special brand of soul.
Crushing our comforts eventually
alienate us from meaning creating
different kinds of misery.
Or as Rick says about ruining summer's
marriage.
Grandpa just sped things up with a few
creature comforts of modern society.
So here's an interesting question that's
a bit speculative,
but the summer,
forgive her father because she sees that
modernization turns every man into an
action list slow,
even if you're a post apocalyptic
badass.
Now I want to speculate a little bit
about Jerry here.
It's likely that rick will stay the same
old uncaring ass he's ever been.
But I think we're gonna see a lot of
character growth in his family members.
Specifically.
Jerry,
what if he has a tyler durden moment
with the Cronenberg Sherry?
What if he liked Edward Norton goes from
being a disaffected modern buffoon to a
man of action.
I mean the show has countless references
to popular cinema and I think a fight
club shout out would work perfect for
Jerry's season three arc.
But Hey,
I guess we're just going to have to see
as season three continues.
Thanks a lot for watching guys.
If you want to hear more about this
week's Rick and morty episode,
we actually just released the first
episode of the wise crack podcast where
we talk all about,
you guessed it,
rick and morty.
So click the link in the description to
check out our podcast and let us know
what you think.
We've got more rick and morty stuff
coming out,
so make sure to subscribe.
Swatch all later.
Piece.